Munira chic is something of a mediator
for the new arrivals the voice of 1200
refugees in antioch western germany it
can get quite crowded here in the room
for the new neighbors at the local town
hall today it's a roundtable for the
women who are keen to find their way
around their new home so there are so
many women who stay at home who only
stay at home don't attend German courses
don't work they don't want to go out
many of the women are nervous about the
freedoms that Germany has to offer what
in Syria was unthinkable is suddenly the
norm in Syria boys and girls are
separated in schools they're all
separated here it's different they're
all together but I don't have so many
problems with it it's okay okay have you
gotten used to it or is it still a bit
strange a bit strange the language is
the most difficult it's very different
to English or Arabic we have to learn a
lot of grammar and talk to people a lot
and that's not easy it takes time right
next door ammonia has direct access to
the local mayor to talk about any
problems the refugees are having the
idea of the new neighbors initiative is
simple refugees help other refugees to
integrate they also get language courses
and the opportunity to mingle with
locals we also invite the refugees to
tell us things like what's your
situation what can we do to support you
and how can we do these things together
so far we found out that our work with
new neighbors has improved the work of
our own administration for fighting
disability Monier has become the city's
most important integration helped her
even though he's only been in Germany
ten months and he still hasn't found a
flat presently he's staying with a
friend they met about a year ago in
Budapest enroute from Syria they were
then part of a large group that started
walking towards Austria then came German
Chancellor Angela Merkel's decision to
open the border to Syrian refugees after
the initial joy came feelings of guilt
look at these pictures I miss my family
this is very difficult for me that I'm
happy here and my family is in Syria
money as parents and siblings live in a
suburb of Damascus still Monier is
grateful for his new life in Germany as
an engineer gardening isn't his strong
suit but he does it happily for the
people of an speck these people here in
Germany have helped us and now they are
helping us with our new lives they
support us and what I'm doing now is
simply trying to give something back
Susanna Keller is a volunteer refugee
helper who regularly assists those who
need help with Germany's bureaucracy or
with translations she supports the new
neighbor initiative wholeheartedly it's
a great program new neighbors is growing
acceptance for them here in the
community that's good and it's fun it's
improving the atmosphere there are
people who are very critical of the
refugees but here we're seeing something
very positive happened come evening
there's yet another meeting in a refugee
home here - everyone's been waiting for
money or to arrive Lanier's current job
is full-time and unpaid but that might
change soon he's just received official
permission to stay in Germany
so he could be getting a paid job soon